standing by marker and action Oscar
memories
can it just be any memory yeah well my
biggest memories when Julia Roberts won
for Aaron Brockovich and I just remember
the way she sauntered up on the stage
an umbrella Coleman's speech which I
thought was a class speech
Billy Crystal and Billy Crystal and
Billy Crystal the thing that uh was most
powerful for me was
being able to meet people whose words
and and works inspired me okay
[Music]
foreign
next to him there was a war in Beatty
scared the crap out of me I thought I'd
be able to be a cool cat who stays chill
but I emphatically was not instead of
saying cheers with my drink I said
cheers with the Oscar and accidentally I
got a big scratch on my Oscar and I'm
not sure to this day if Brad Pitt also
has a scratch on his Oscar I actually
met Snoop Dogg got a selfie with him
it's still the picture on my Facebook
page to this day I remember my father
who was my date running away from me at
the speed of light because he'd seen
Julie Andrews and was determined to have
a long conversation with her the shoe my
wife fell very low into the dungeons of
the theater so you know while she had
just one shoe I think about Oscars
mostly it's just about a celebration of
art I absolutely loved the moment when I
went Rika won for period end of sentence
in 2019 period end of Saturday I always
looked at Leo's career
[Music]
that was the Oscars that Darlene Love
one of the greatest voices in American
music history brought the house down
I remember when parasite won parasite
the entire room just exploded and I have
no idea what it felt like watching on TV
but in the room it felt like a rock
concert the parasite Suite was one of
the greatest things that's ever happened
we had one of those nights where we had
11 wins out of 11 nominations Lord of
the Rings Lord of the Rings Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King and we
partied in Peter Jackson's room all
night long myself and my whole family
they were in front of the TV with all
excitement
[Music]
we had a projector and a projection
screen and cooked up a storm and we're
watching the awards and Joel and Ethan
win for best original screenplay Ethan
and Joel Cohen for Fargo and in the
middle of speech Joel says I'd like to
thank everyone over at Mary zofre's
house I guess this woke you guys up and
the
Bruce went bonkers it was one of the
most special experiences and evenings of
my life